[Music]
i think i was writing from a place of
probably for the first time since i was
15 getting a real kind of couple months
off camila and i were just in miami for
a couple months everything was stopped
and we were able to just find
ourselves sitting down with siriusxm's
the pulse sean also says his new single
which features reggaeton producer tiny
likely isn't a one-off i'm always
working on new music and maybe i hope
maybe something else will come before
the end of the year
[Music]
as for his long time love camila cabello
john tells the morning mashup they've
learned to navigate their everyday ups
and downs in a healthy way we have a
really honest and open relationship but
yeah no we definitely fight definitely
not that holding hands all the time but
we're really good with each other yeah
it never gets bad it's always like a
little cycle it was the summer
[Music]
and in tonight's love meter are zoe
kravitz and channing tatum having their
own summer of love the pair were snapped
in new york this week as always
strolling next to the magic mike star as
he biked through the city's east village
they're currently working on a film
project together with chatting in the
league role and zoe making her
directorial debut a source did tell
e-news back in january that the two were
not an item outside of work but this new
sighting definitely has people talking
now while the zoe enchanting speculation
heats up we do know for certain that
livna's ex is head over heels for his
new
the chart topper guys the september
issue of the man and though he doesn't
reveal the identity of his new boyfriend
he says this about his mystery man i
feel like this is one of the best
relationships yet i'm really happy about
it and it all just feels natural it's
effortless